Now you've had a lot of practice, making, and traversing array lists, but what
if you want to modify their contents? You know how to get an element, and if
you want to change it, you use a very similar method, the set method. So, over
here, we're calling set, with an index, and the new value. Whatever was there
before at position two is now replaced with this new value. In the next
exercise you will see a couple of lines of code involving get and set that try
to swap two pictures in our gallery but when you run it you'll see it's not
working. Your job is to fix it. Here's the bad code, let's see what's bad about
it. When you run the program, then the gallery looks like this. Clearly it is
not swapping. The pictures had position one and two. Instead, there's seems to
be a gap here. Let's, first of all, understand that gap before we go and fix
it. Here's the original gallery. Let me write the index values so it makes it
easier to follow along what happens. Now, we're taking the element at position
one, that's this fellow here. And now we're setting this one here to this
picture. So now, over here, this element is also that same guy, pardon my
drawing skills, obviously I'm not Gauguin. We get that's this fellow again and
put him into slot one. So what we would expect is to see him twice maybe.
Except remember that what we we're having in the array list are not objects,
but object references. So here's what the array list really looks like. The
zero slot, as a reference to this object. The one and two slot have a reference
to the exact same object, and then the three and four point to these ones, and
I won't draw those arrows. The point is that these ones are the exact same
object, and so it's drawn twice, but you don't see that because it gets drawn
on top of itself. The gap was just an artifact of the positioning. Never mind
the gap, what's important is that if you first copy this one over here you wipe
out the element that's in here and then when you copy back then you just get
two identical values in the array. That's no good. So what we need to do is
instead of wiping out the bridge here at position two, we need to save it.
Let's do that. Here we're saving the old value. At slot two, then we can set
slot two to what we want. And now here, instead of using the new value, we'll
use the old one. I'll go ahead and run this and you'll see that the elements at
one and two are swapped. Here you see them. Get and set are certainly the most
basic operations on an array list. But there are a bunch of others that are
also quite convenient. Let's have a look at those.